each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
thank you very much for joining me for
the stock today as it is clear from this
title slide here I represent
computational biology service unit which
is one of the core facilities at Cornell
University the mission of our unit is to
provide the widely understood
computational support and research
support for biological research at
Cornell University in particular we
maintain several windows-based computer
clusters which we make available to
Cornell community but actually our
influences so to say reach far beyond
Cornell and we have a lot of users and
hopefully a lot of friends also all over
the world and one thing that we learned
from this computational support that we
providing is that convenience of access
to hpc resources is the major issue in
biology the fact is that HPC is badly
needed in biological sciences but really
researchers would rather spend their
time doing the research rather than
figuring out how to submit a job or
write a script or stuff like this I
guess that's the statement that we've
heard a lot during during that
conference so our approach to solving
this problem of convenience of access to
hpc resources has been web-based user
interface to our to our clusters this
has been developed at CBS you for a
number of years and has been working
pretty well essentially this is a web
interface written in asp.net consisting
of a bunch of submission pages which the
users can use to submit different kinds
of applications to our to our clusters
so we have about 30 applications in
total here is an example of such a
submission page for blass
just paralyzed and we have also other
applications in different categories
including population genetics which is
now becoming very popular so we have a
lot of programs in population genetics
so what the user has to do is to just
fill out this form provide all the
necessary input files and set some
parameters and then click the submit
button which unfortunately didn't make
it to the slide and our interface the
code behind such a such a page takes
care of everything else and we have this
interface which is called bio HPC we
have this described in a poster the
poster is very easy to spot it's all
green so you can say that in a way it
really stands out so so please come and
visit while the web interfaces has been
working very well for us we have been
pondering the question for some time
whether or not to expose our
applications as web services this would
have some impact for our users for
example it would allow them to
incorporate our applications directly in
their analysis pipelines and another
advantage would be that we would get rid
of the limitation of a web form as a
user interface in particular jobs could
be submitted and data would could be
retrieved from a client of choice for
example a lot of biologists use excel as
a tool to store and organize and analyze
their data so it would be really nice to
be able to submit HPC tasks dialect
directly from Excel and then retrieve
data and analyze them also in Excel and
while we have been pondering this
question we came across a relatively new
product from Microsoft HPC team the
product is called computational finance
server and as the name suggests it has
been designed designed mostly for
computational finance applications
however it is in fact pretty open-ended
general tool for deployment and
execution
of hpc tasks it is web service based and
it features excel 2007 as the user
interface so it is sort of something
what we have looking for so we decided
as a proof of concept and feasibility
test to adopt a few of our popular
computational biology applications to
complain and to confidence the short
name for this computational finance
server so to start with we adapted a
program called structure which is one of
the most popular pieces of software in
the community of population geneticist
at least according to the statistics
collected through our web interface so
here's the outline of my talk and first
I'm going to talk a little bit about
what structure is when what it does then
I'm going to highlight some points about
a conf in and I'm going to describe our
company implementation of structure so
what is structure the objective of the
program is to split a group of
individuals in two populations or
clusters based on the known genetic
characteristics of this individual so
it's essentially a clustering problem
however it's a little bit different from
what we usually think about clustering
usually there is some distance involved
in that now here we don't have distance
instead we have a statistical model
consisting of several components so
first of all we have
works well first of all we have the set
of a genomic data which we called
collectively denoted by X ensure these
alleles at several lot C for a set of
individuals and come back to the
structure of this data set in a minute
then we have a number of populations
that we want the program to try to split
the set of individuals into and we have
our model variable so these things are
fixed and now we have our model
variables which are about multi
dimensional vectors we have the vector Z
collecting assignment of individuals to
populations and we have the vector P
which collects allele frequencies within
these populations and the model gives us
the prescription to calculate the
probability conditional probability of
obtaining experimental result x provided
that p and z are what they are so what
structure does it is trying to obtain
sort of the best fit that the p + z
which provides all the best fit to this
data and of course there may be many
definitions of what we consider to be
the best fit one obvious choice would be
to simply maximize this probability with
respect to p + z which would boil down
to a maximum likelihood method what
structure does is a little bit different
it uses the approach based on bias drm
to calculate the posterior probability
distribution of enz given the data so to
do this we need to assume some suitable
priors on pio on p + + z the method that
the program uses to estimate this
posterior probability distribution is
Markov chain Monte Carlo simulation
which essentially consists of generating
long chain of different C&P combinations
it's jumps from one to the other
according to some acceptance rules and
generates a lot of them and can go into
thousands or millions or hundreds of
millions depending on the particular
need and once this is does this creates
a sample of Z and P or if you wish
multi-dimensional
program which is an estimate of this
probability in question and once we have
this estimate we can do whatever people
usually do with probability
distributions we can generate some
summary statistics averages variances
confidence intervals and so on and so
forth so in particular primary output
from the from this program is a table of
infant ancestral individuals which is
essentially a list of probabilities of
it of each individual belonging to each
population and this is roughly speaking
average of the vector Z over the
distribution and another component about
Buddhist inferred allele frequencies
with populations within populations and
this is roughly speaking an average of
the vector P there are also some other
output parameters which I don't want to
talk about here what I wanted to talk to
point out is something a little bit on
the technical node structure is
something that would be called the dis
conference a legacy code this is
something written in C probably
definitely not in c-sharp downloaded
from a develop developers website as a
free code it has input it takes input
and in the form of text files and also
splits the output in the form of a form
of text files so this is something is
definitely a legacy code something that
would be called a legacy code and this
is something that you are trying to
squeeze into this convent environment
now an important thing to realize is
that for a given genomic data set X we
need to do multiple independent runs of
structure first of all we need to figure
out which number of populations is the
best because we don't know it in advance
so we need to run make a lot of rounds
with different numbers of populations
even with the same number of population
we have to make sure that our results
are consistent because this is after all
Monte Carlo simulation which can go
astray sometimes can get trapped in
local maxima and provide unreliable
results so we need to repeat
them a couple of times at least to make
sure that we are on the same page with
all the rounds finally we want to try
sometimes different control parameters
that control is mcmc process each of
such multiple simulations is pretty long
can take hours to days and therefore
structure could really benefit from the
compute cluster it's an HP see task and
benefit from the computer cluster we can
run each of these independent
simulations separately on a sub
processor and get in the form of given
the form of input-output it could also
benefit from Excel user interface for
example these text output files now
there are kind of itching to be imported
into exile and visualize somehow or
analyzed otherwise so let's structure so
now what is this computational finance
server so first of all it's a set of
functions and a p.a programmers
interface which abstracts from specific
implementation details of java of things
like job scheduler or storage then so
this is something that lets us interact
with the whole environment next there is
a web service layer which is used to
submit and monitor jobs and also
eventually to retrieve the output data
there is a program called task pane an
excel addin which essentially makes
Excel a client to consume these web
services share the microsoft sharepoint
server is used to like a meeting point
to to store the excel templates at an
actual binaries of the program that we
are trying to deploy there is microsoft
sequel server which is used as the data
storage of course we have to have a
cluster running Windows Server 2008 and
also I know that initially the whole
system was running on the previous
version of the Microsoft cluster
software and finally last but not least
since this is a computational finance
server it sports
have the sequel database of historical
market data which we are not going to
use here as computational biologists we
are not that interested in historical
market baby so so we have a bunch of
Microsoft productivity tools good
together to provide uniform platform for
deployment and and execution of tasks on
a computer cluster so to make it a
little bit more clear let us consider a
question what does it take to deploy a
comfy application so first of all if we
want to deploy a comp application we
need to create an Excel template with
some cells or tables within it designate
it to be input search they will hold our
input data and likewise some other set
of cells will hold output data and since
in the spirit of web services this Excel
workbook will be talking XML to the rest
of the content environment these tables
have to be mapped onto certain xml
schemas so we need to divide the xml
schemas which we think will describe our
model best and this mapping can be done
in a very standard way within Excel
Excel has this XML map feature which can
be used here so another thing that we
need to prepare is a little piece of C
sharp code which is which is actually
going to interface our program with the
conf in environment so it's going to
accept the XML input from Excel and it's
going to transfer deserialize it into
the sheet of structures data contracts
then based on this input is going to
decide how many independent structure
runs we want to run and will launch Pugh
up appropriate tasks now each of these
tasks will be doing the actual number
crunching as I said the number crunching
is done by a separate executable which
we have here as a part of our system
so each of these task will have to
create the required temple txt files
launch the executable then parse the
outputs load them into appropriate
c-sharp structures without beta
contracts and then finally output them
as XML from the program now all these
things the input output hand link and
also the the launching of tasks which
obviously require some sort of
interaction with the job scheduler these
are taken care of by the RP so this is
pretty transparent to a programmer we
don't have to worry about how the
scheduler works or how to serialize or
dis you realize the the data everything
is taken care of by pretty simple to
call up functions so finally the output
data will be stored in the storage which
is located somewhere close to the
cluster and there's a lot of
implementations possible for this result
storage but this implemented right now
is storage in the in terms of sequel
tables so basically all this XML is
loaded into sequel a sequel tables and
start there until it is retrieved by
clicking a button in inside Excel
through the appropriate web service so
finally why these why are these two
components of our implementation are are
done the Excel workbook and this C sharp
rapper code we upload both of these
components into the dedicated SharePoint
site which is going to make it possible
for other users to retrieve it and run
it so the bird's-eye view of the whole
system the way it looks from the users
perspective is this so we have our user
with the laptop what he needs to do
first is to fire up the Internet
Explorer and contact the SharePoint site
in order to retrieve the Excel template
where he work is going to supply the
input so this Excel template opens up
and on the user's machine he supplies
the input and after that he saves it
back into the excel but back into the
SharePoint site which is serving also as
a kind of a job repository where all
these Excel workbooks corresponding to
different jobs are being stored and once
the the workbook the workbook is saved
the user clicks submit button in the
Excel which calls job launching web
service and triggers all kinds of
complicated events here which eventually
lead to launching of the whole job so
all this all this part of this
complicated part is completely hidden
from the user of course they are the
only thing that he has to worry about is
this part and then once the job is
complete the user gets notified and then
he clicks another button in order to
retrieve the data from the xml xq el
storage and there's another web service
running here that takes care of that so
let's see what does it look like in in
in practice so first we login to the
SharePoint site that's what it looks
like and we we open our my modest
library link is called from where we can
retrieve a template of our structure job
and this template once we do that the
template opens up in in excel on our
local machine and it opens up to the
well welcome message containing some
instructions for the first time users
specifying how to use the program and
the next thing we need to do is to
supply the data so this is the actual
actual genomic data sample genomic data
denoted by X and well what it is we can
see that okay so the first column is the
identity identifier of an individual so
we have a bunch of individuals here the
first one is called one the second one
is called ten the third one is called
1229 I think something like that then
the second column
and we have like 155 of them not all of
them are shown the second column stands
for some other characteristics of this
individuals like for example geographic
location here and the rest of columns
they contain identifiers of the alleles
found at the number of lot C so for here
for example we have 70 zl1 through of 7
and these integers here they may have
some physical meaning for example when
we deal with microsatellite data but
other than that they are just labels
pretty much now each individual is
deployed which means that it has two
instances of which locals so that's why
we have two lines per each individual
and for instance if we see if we look at
individual number 10 and locals one we
see that the alleles at this locus are
the same we say that this individual is
homozygous at locust one on the other
hand if we if we look at the same
individual locust locust 5 for example
we see that the alleles are the two
alleles are different which makes this
individual a heterozygote in this locus
so this is pretty much the type of data
input data that structure accepts and
that's pretty much a pretty well
structured and suitable to be to be
stored and processed in Excel so once
this is ready just press the this button
here which activates a macro which in
turns transfer this to the appropriately
XML mapped portion of the of the
workbook so the genomic data is there so
what we need to do now is
specify other run parameters so that
this looks a little bit cryptic for now
but all the resources were actually use
structure in the research would know
what all this parameter mean parameters
mean for instance we have the number of
individuals specified here we have the
plurality of them we have other
parameters the most important part of
this input is probably this we have 15
lines here we have we can have as many
lines as we possibly want and each of
the lines corresponds to one individual
structure run that we want to execute as
I said before we need to execute several
rounds for each number of populations
case for example here we are scanning
numbers of populations from one to five
when we are doing three runs for each of
these numbers you can also specify a
number of steps of the actual simulation
and burnin can do it separately for each
run but here actually they happen to be
to be the same so basically this table
tells the program to execute 15 separate
structure runs with these parameters and
the other parameter parameters will be
common to all these runs so once all the
data is there the next thing we need to
do is we need to save this workbook back
into the sharp or inside right using the
save button and then once this is done
we just submit the job by clicking
submit and when we do that the Prada
actually by the way this piece of Excel
window here that we see is the task pane
that's that's this web service client
which is a which is an excel add-in it
has to be installed in Excel if you want
to use it as the as the interface to the
conflict so it has many functions and
one of them is just submitting the job
that we that we just did while the job
is running we can monitor its progress
using the standard progress bar and when
the job is done we get notified that the
job just completed we do not have to
keep the Excel workbook open
all the time we can just go for coffee
or go on vacation depending on the
duration of the computations that we are
doing if we go for coffee and close the
workbook in the meantime can always come
back to it reopen it again and we will
have this notification waiting for us so
once the job completes we are ready to
retrieve the data and there is a special
button here in the task pane that does
it for us we click this button the data
is streamed into the XML mapped
designated areas designated for output
so this is an example of these areas we
have a special worksheet here that
collects all these XML mops and you can
see that you know XML map is mildly
human readable if you really want there
you can extract some information from it
just by looking at it but there is a
better way to do this and this way is
based on standard Excel mechanisms pivot
tables pivot charts and also visual
basic macros so this is what we do we
basically the table that you just saw we
process it through the pivot table
mechanism and this is what we obtain
here so that's this is essentially the
record of all our 50 in the summary of
all our 15 runs and some basic results
from all these simulations are listed
here in particular we have the number of
populations which was the input actually
and we have this logarithm probability
of data which is actually a very
important number because it tells us it
allows us to to tell which population
number is the best for example we can
see here that for populated for three
populations this number is the least
negative except for this for this mellow
result here but other two are the least
negative of all and that's basically the
indicative that there's three
populations that the data implies three
populations now how about this point
that sticks out as i said the monte
carlo simulation sometimes can go astray
sometimes not equilibrated too well and
that's this is
an example of such of such occurrence
one way of analyzing the results of the
run is to monitor the parameters which
are sampled during the run so one way of
monitoring them is to make a histogram
out of them and we can make a histogram
of any parameters this actually opens up
as a drop-down list from which we can
select which parameter to view so for
example here we have a parameter called
alpha which is has a distribution
centers around a pretty small number
much less than one and the theory tells
us that this means that individuals are
mostly purely from one population or the
other there is no genetic not too much
at least genetic admixture between
different populations individuals so
this is a kind of information that we
can get that we can get at our
fingertips out of out of this again we
can make several you can make a lot of
plots this is actually a pivot chart
which is created out of another pivot
table which illustrates the allele
frequencies here at locust too for
example we can see that a lil number two
is most abundant one in populations one
and two and this plot summarizes the
ancestry of individuals basically each
individual is represented by it by point
located somewhere inside an equilateral
triangle and if this point is very close
to one of the corners of the triangle
each corner corresponds to a 22 to a
different population so if an individual
is in the corner it belongs to this
population at least this is this what
this is what the genetic composition of
this individual tells us so here okay
and every individual also has a shape
and the color associated with it which
correspond to some different prior istic
of individuals in this case this is a
location where they when they give an
individual was caught and we can see
that usually at least in this example
the geographical location sort of
corresponds to the genetically derived
populations however there are some
outliers for instance this guy here he
has the genetic composition of
population too but it was found in the
area or the population population one
sorry but it was found that the area
where the population lives population
two lives so this kind of this kind of
of course invites all kinds of
scientific questions and this
information is also a viable hyrum at
our fingertips to EXO and last but not
least for those who would prefer to have
a row text output from the program this
is available as well which can be this
can be just exported from Excel using
standard export mechanism so what does
the verdict is the comp is confident a
good platform for computational biology
applications well certainly powerful
Excel interface helps very much we can
do a lot more with this interface that
with any other stand-alone graphical
application which which could analyze
the data from this particular program
it's relatively easy to deploy to the
confident environment there is not too
much programming involved in this and
finally confident offers this on sites
data storage we which we have not used
here because we didn't have such a such
a need however this is something really
to consider in view of the very
data-intensive applications such as
next-generation sequencing in fact
confident has been developed with this
idea of bringing computational power to
the data rather than data to
computational power and that looks like
something which would be useful for
computational biology but for example
envision company installation somewhere
close to a sequencer which generates
huge amounts of data which then have to
be analyzed on an HP SI system there are
things that could be improved to make
Infiniti better platform for
computational biology for example
currently all the input and output data
transfer is exclusively through Excel so
this is very nice but what if we have
some binary data to transfer or what if
our data is not really excel it's not
pretty enough or not informative enough
to be put into Excel or what if it has
to 20 gigabytes for instance also there
are some issues with the transfer of
output from the sequel storage to excel
to xml maps this may not be too
efficient for very large data sets I'm
sure it can be improved more actually it
has been improved greatly as as the
result of this project but it is a
concern and another thing that is a
little bit i would say annoying from our
point of view is that in order to use
conf in the user needs a domain account
on the cluster so this seems to be good
for small closed organizations corporate
organizations for instance but not so
much for an open university research
environment for example in our bio HPC
web-based user interface the number of
independent users that actually utilize
it is what a couple of thousand now our
clusters live in wider environment
provided by our departmental CIT people
and they would be really upset we ask
them to suddenly set up two thousand
domain accounts just to just to use the
system so some sort of a way to allow
guest users would be really useful to be
programmed it to do this into the system
so finally let me acknowledge financial
support from Microsoft hpc Institute
program that will and peridot for a
number of years and more recently from
microsoft research as well as fruitful
collaboration with the microsoft HPC
team in particular Rachel Sibella and
Dino sign thank you for your